the organizers of the event asked mr.
Abraham co-author of none dare call it
conspiracy to tape his remarks they were
played during his scheduled session this
event is about 50 minutes thank you
it's with joy and sadness that I that I
give this talk Larry Abraham wanted
desperately to be here this week and to
give this talk himself in person and it
was about two weeks ago that he called
and we talked about any such around I
want to be there and if I could just if
you could just beam me up I'd do it but
he knew that physically he couldn't make
the flight and and maneuver the hotel
and be here and so we said well let's do
it by videotape we really want your last
lecture a last lecture is what a person
would say to sum up the lesson in life
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in life and Larry really wanted
to do that so he agreed to do it and it
was a week ago today on Saturday that
his daughter went into his office with
him and Larry's just as dapper as ever
he was so well dressed and so handsome
and and and - the last - his last day he
was so that he videotaped him doing this
giving his last lecture and then she was
editing it and it really took it all out
of him and he literally collapsed after
giving this talk and I felt terrible
about that
I when I heard my heart just sank that
we had done that to him then I heard
what happened after that he rallied his
family came they were there and he was
so anxious to see the edited version to
see what we were going to see today and
he kept saying to his daughter Keely is
it ready is it ready to bring it over I
want to see it I want to see it so he
saw it last Monday his whole family was
there his children his grandchildren his
dear wife Sophie he watched it he
laughed he chuckled he reminisced he
talked about what a glorious thing it
was to be part of the freedom movement
Keely went to DHL to send the the
the DVD to us and half an hour later
Larry lapsed into a coma and died two
hours later with Sophie holding him and
she said that he was so peaceful and at
rest and happy that he knew his life had
meaning he was surrounded by his family
and having given this last lecture sorry
breaking up he's been a dear dear friend
for 30 years and you know before there
was the internet before there was Google
before there was Wikipedia there was
Larry Abraham's brain Larry had almost
Total Recall and a while he always
prepared his talks he never used a note
and you'll see that in this DVD today
totally prepared
but without a note and it to the very
end no notes no teleprompter and just
Larry Abraham's magnificent brain we
hope you'll enjoy this as much as he
enjoyed making it for you
[Applause]
[Music]
first of all let me thank mark and
Joanne Skousen for the privilege of
speaking at Freedom Fest this is a
remarkable conference and one that I
really look forward to speaking out
every year it hasn't been that many
years but they have been proud years and
when they asked me to speak this year I
immediately said yes looking forward to
this opportunity I didn't know what I
would be able to do it
because I'm kind of marching my last
days but we worked it out more with the
help of my daughter Kelly and her
operation we would be able to make this
event I would be able to give the speech
hopefully with alacrity and and
capability and do it in such a way is
that it would make it something that I'm
proud to be a part of this will be 40
years of giving speeches on this subject
the subject being first principles the
things that make what we stand for all
valuable and all important I started
giving speeches on first principles back
in the 1960s and I'm really proud to
have been able to do it with some air of
capability so thank you mark and Joanne
for this capability and opportunity that
makes it all worthwhile
I want to tell you what the first
principles mean to me and what they
should mean to you and all of us we
build our lives around capabilities and
ideas that means something to all of us
and our families and I know it's
truthful for all of the people just
conference or at least those who make up
this conference the first principles
that make up our lives
or God family country property those are
the things that make it all worthwhile I
remember back in the early 60s when I
was just a young man I was looking to
find those values that that would be of
value to me and my family and the things
that first made it so or what I found
going on
Claro Verena wobegon area of south
africa calls the Katanga province is
there in the Katanga province a young
Christian by the name of Boise xianbei
and was doing the best he could to
provide leadership for his people in a
way that would allow them to build lives
of value only to find that everything
they tried to do everything they had
tended to do was being undermined by the
forces of the United Nations
organization and they were doing it in a
brutal way they were attacking and it
was genocide it was all to the benefit
of a young Communist revolutionary by
the name of Patrice Lumumba Lumumba was
using everything he could to dispose
some bay and his people and take control
of the rich copper provinces so that he
could go ahead and wage a civil war
against his own people and use that
money to build this conference in this
Congolese capability into it a nightmare
that would allow him to virtually
destroy those people that were working
so hard to find a new life a new
capability that was so shocking to me
then it was a real eye-opener it allowed
me to start looking at other things and
say wow what's happening here
and why would the United States and the
Western countries like Belgium for
example allow this capability to go
unchallenged
well that served as a real eye-opener
and it served as a as a way to start
taking a look at other things that were
more vicious in their in their
ramifications then from there we looked
on and we looked at other capabilities
that were being unleashed that were not
good not capable and certainly not in
the defense of freedom so here we are 40
years later and I've been looking and
continuing to look and I'm very proud of
what was what we've been able to do
we've been able to write books we've
been able to do to do things in the area
of launching newsletters and launching
efforts that have been so valuable that
have helped serve our colleagues in so
many ways of which we are very proud now
as we look down through the vast panoply
of effort you come to find out that
there's another whole area that is so
vitally important to what we're trying
to do the lessons were trying to leave
to friends and fellow freedom fighters
around the world that's vital and and
almost unbelievable who would have
thought 40 years ago that while we were
fighting for the freedom effort in the
area of Congo that 40 years later we
would find ourselves involved in a
battle it would not only serve to help
the people in South Africa but also the
people in places like China I could
never have believed back in the 1960s
fighting for the vision of freedom in
China would be an integral part of what
we're doing here
as I traveled to China today now I find
that a Chinese people are in the
forefront of this
battle for freedom of ideas and that's
the part that is really intriguing we
find that we are in the battle for the
freedom of ideas and that's I guess that
has always been the case we've always
been in the battle for the freedom of
ideas and this battle for the freedom of
ideas is at the core of what we're doing
and it will be at the core of what we're
going to be doing first far into the
future as we can see many people for
generations thought that really Mao
Zedong was right power grew out of the
barrel of a gun he was it was wrong on
so many things
there is no power coming out of the
barrel intends today power is coming out
of that the ideas and that's why
Clifford's is like this are so vitally
important what do they do they sponsor
and promote ideas ideas of this type
that are being Washington and burnished
and cleaned up and sent around the world
it's amazing to see how many people that
came out of the universities at the time
I did work regulated almost into not
believing anything because it was
considered by the professor's as beneath
investigation that ideas like
intelligent design were not only not
worthy of investigation they were
beneath anything of that sort they were
held up to contempt now those of you who
don't know what we're talking about here
I'm missing the fight of a lifetime the
whole idea that people could believe in
something other than Darwinian evolution
is considered beneath contempt and an
almost whole idea that doesn't deserve
anything other than a complete disregard
we can do the same thing with so many
other ideas
our young stepson is going to the
University of Chicago Nick his amazed at
what he finds out as he goes through his
undergraduate studies as to what is held
up as worthy of of examination if he
studies anything he's going to find that
a zero-sum game is only understood by
those who believe in socialism and and
as he studies and takes a look at the
world around him he's finding out that
such is not the case a zero-sum game
does not know tribute to anything -
that's the bad better glory of mankind
it just leaves out the idea that one
man's game can be another man's gain and
that these capabilities are being held
out on a daily basis that one man's gain
be another man's game
let the rising tide lifts all ships let
the let the economic battery of
capability provide capability for
everyone that's the part that is so
exciting and that's the part that makes
our lives and these principles that we
believe in so so important and what we
are finding is that if you present these
ideas as are being done here at this
conference not only are these ideas
accepted they are found to be intriguing
and that brings these these students
together makes them on the right mind
when I was preparing my thoughts for
this presentation I started to give
ideas try to give design to where would
we go from here
where are them where the battles going
to be fine what are the people going to
be carrying on there are their arguments
there are slots and I guess it's pretty
simple really as I look at it right now
is that look forward to the next four
years
I think the battles are going to be
fought of that in the classrooms
and in the front rooms they're going to
be looking at Americans to to carry on
fights it weighs it we could never have
anticipated before the cultural war as I
guess it's being called are the ideas
that are going to be engaged when I take
a look at it I see it and wrapped up in
me Marxist ideas of Antonio Gramsci
the Italian marks us to come back to as
it came to the fight and says ok let's
admit it fellow Marxist we lost the war
as it relates to economics we lost the
war as it relates to battlegrounds
perhaps you when he was a young
communist in Italy back in the 20s come
to realize that this was beyond their
capability they were not capable and so
they come to realize that if they're
gonna win they're gonna win by tearing
away that's a very core ideas that make
up Western civilization perhaps you
believe that you'll win this war by
tearing out the heart and soul by
destroying a very core of Western
cultural ideas as a frating concept
because cultural ideas are brought up
and nurtured over a long period of time
and if your diffic and destroy cultural
ideas you end up destroying what makes
for the very heart of the culture and it
starts with family ideas looking back
over easier and what they represent we
have to really come to to grips with
them with what makes it of them what is
a what is a first principle
first principle is something that you're
willing to fight for it's something
you're willing to die for I'm proud of
the fact that my grandson Benjamin yes
in his Marine unit cease fighting he's
not dying hopefully but he's fighting in
such a way as to to be a a guardian for
first principles he's willing to do it
and I am willing to support him for it
in every step of the way and such as the
way with regard to engaging how do you
win the war you would not necessarily
with what's the battle of tons of
bullets you know what with ideas the one
with ideas and that's why I applaud mark
enjoy and for freedom fest the ability
to fight the war in ways that promote
the ideas the ideas are really what's
critical so probably looking at the
realities of my health problems I won't
make it back next year but that's okay I
won't be resting with thee was here with
the offensive bullets but I will be
arguing with what is that corner what is
what's what's key how I be able to have
done it well I would have been able to
do it the way we're doing it now sharing
ideas and ways that make this a very
powerful conduit what I would like to do
now some mr ideas
moved around and and examined I'll be
sitting by the telephone waiting
telephone calls so - so if you will tell
me to stop the monologue I don't stop
the monologue and we will go forward by
taking questions from the audience
again thank you mark and Joanne for
inviting me if there are any questions
I'd be delighted
well technology has accomplished wonders
but unfortunately Larry we don't have a
telephone that can reach you now Larry
was an inspiration to me in in many many
different ways practical philosophical
financial but one Joanne mentioned he
was without a doubt the snappiest
dresser I ever knew he was always
impeccably dressed but differently
differently and one of the things that
was his trademark was colorful shirts
and matching socks I got to tell you 20
years ago that was very unusual there
was a time when the four horsemen mark
Skousen Larry Abraham Doug Casey and
Gary North joined sometimes by Jack
Pugsley way a traveling Roadshow that
went around the country with a one-day
seminar on investments and I forget
where this occurred but I remember it
distinctly because a couple had brought
their son who is probably 10 years old
they were welcome to do that to the
similar and they were sitting in the
front row Larry got up to start making
his remarks and you could hear the Sun
turn to his mommy
and say with wonder mom he's wearing
green socks and he was he had bright
forest green socks to match his bright
forest green
shirt so I don't know if we can get a
close-up of this but I want you to see
Larry these socks are for you well then
we had a discussion about okay what else
do we want to do with the rest of this
hour and you have to understand that
there there is a strong streak of McCobb
humor among among many of us in the
libertarian conservative movement and
I've I don't know who's who said it and
I'm not sure I should quote it but I
will because somebody said well let's
get Marshall Fritz up here to talk he's
dying to some of you have already heard
Marshall at one of his workshops he's
accomplished so much of the many things
he will be remembered for besides a
wonderful sardonic sense of humor is the
world's smallest political quiz I don't
know how many he has with him but I hope
he has one for everyone in the audience
because it really has had a profound
effect for its tiny little size on what
a lot of people recognize about Larry
Abraham as would say first principles so
Marshall to close out this part of the
program would you come up with some
inspiring thoughts and if you don't feel
like inspiring then just tell jokes and
make us laugh as you as you have so
often in the past ladies and gentlemen
please join me in welcoming Marshall
Fritz
[Applause]
Thank You Joanne and Mark for inviting
me and may he rest in peace Larry
Abraham I didn't know Larry but I've
gotten to know him today watching the
video twice and I sure like the guy
although a few years ago I decided that
I'd had enough of dark blue charcoal and
black socks and I bought 24 pair of
black socks gave all my other socks to
my son also has large feet and and I now
wear black socks with practically
everything although Sharon airs once
pointed out to me I shouldn't wear them
with shorts so I got some white socks
for those yes here are some copies of
the quiz chip and how you deliver these
to everybody or we'll leave them up here
that's fine he's going to have the cards
on the table by the back door I should
mention too that this hat is not
particularly a fashion statement I'm
enjoying a close quote terminal
pancreatic cancer and the treatment for
it which has no hope of eliminating the
cancer you can put a dryer and a shirt
in a dryer and it shrinks the shirt but
it doesn't eliminate the shirt so this
chemo shrinks the tumor but it doesn't
eliminate it and makes my head cold and
so I tried baseball cap and it doesn't
keep it warm enough and I then I tried a
couple of ski caps they look not only
out of season but a little bit silly and
I thought well when I lived in Pakistan
our family staff all were Bhutan's and
wore this kind of a hat it's called a
POC hole and my mood wore it the guy who
took on the northern what led the
Northern Alliance and took on the
Taliban so if this has some reminiscence
in your
memory there that it's probably from the
Northern Alliance up in the Northeast
Afghanistan so anyway my wife said
you're not going to wear that silly
thing on you're being filmed on c-span
are you and I said well of course not
honey
and so I hi Joan so I took it off there
it's wondering who's that over my
shoulder and then turn around and look
at it's me over my shoulder so I'll have
to ignore the peripheral vision on my
own last lecture
mark Skousen asked me about a month or
so ago in fact we've had four pre
weights I decided that it won't be any
fun for me at my wake because I won't be
awake and I want to be awake at my awake
so I talked to some friends and they
started throwing wakes for me in
different parts of the country so we had
wanted Lana to and Fresno and then one
down in Hollywood various people came
and and some of them said nice things
and others told the truth and some
really silly stories about things that I
had done or whatever and I got a chance
for a short rebuttal but but I never did
get down to really serious brass tacks
and give a last lecture in any of those
four and so today is my opportunity mark
called just a couple three days ago and
said Larry looks pretty weak we've got
some time to fill here would you come
Marshall please and and I checked with
my wife to make sure that it was okay
with her and she said yes so she's on a
plane winging we're way home right now
but gave me permission to stay over my
policy for many years has been God first
family second and all the rest of things
tied for third equally important to me
has been my policy of exercising 20 to
30 minutes a day and
you know eating sensibly in practice I
exercise 10 to 20 minutes a year and ate
sensibly rarely and it was always
walking around 50 60 pounds overweight
and you know not a good thing for a guy
who's had a heart attack the guy has
diabetes didn't hurt my cancer doctor
didn't worry a bit about it I had
another cancer - this is the second one
I hope I don't get a third but I've been
hustling with prostate cancer who since
96 and that's God's gift to
procrastinators world's slowest cancer
and so I used to brag on having the
world's slowest cancer then I got
pancreatic cancer
describe to me did that told to me in
February of this year five months ago
and I scratched my head and said to the
doctor oh that's that three to six
months stuff and he says oh no we can
keep he'll live longer than that so I
talked to him and we negotiated some and
and anyway we got it to six to twenty
months and that was five months ago and
let me tell you I haven't subtracted one
day from that so people asked me and I
said I got six to twenty months and if I
catch a miracle that'll be six to twenty
years and about one percent it seems
catch a miracle so we can always pray
for that but to tell you the truth I
tell people particularly those who want
to pray for me and I say well pray for
virtue I need patience
I need faith I need wisdom I need
fortitude a lot more than I need a
longer life I've had 65 years some very
very good rest pretty good got 12
wonderful grandchildren for two
wonderful children one wonderful wife
and so I'm okay to go
I'm really okay with it now when I get
down to three or four days or something
I made and I have my panic I don't know
but I haven't had my panic yet and and
I'm ready to go not eager
but ready now what would I say to
somebody and if I really did sit to be
blunt
oh I would say if you know God great if
you don't know God start the search for
him or restart the search for it it
might be very very important Milton
Friedman and I got the opportunity to
discuss vouchers in we're in his living
room and we had about a three-hour
discussion one afternoon and I'll tell
you when truth goes up against
brilliance
you're lucky to pull a draw I had the
truth vouchers are bad and he had the
brilliance that man has brains IQ and
intelligence where I've got sinuses it's
just something to arm wrestle with
Milton Friedman using logic and that
sort of thing and but as part of it he
told me his own spiritual Odyssey and
his relationship or thoughts about God
and how he concluded at age 11 and I
always point out to people how smart
this guy was this is prepubescence and
he figured out that it was impossible to
keep all 613 laws of the Jewish law and
there couldn't be a guy that would make
such a impossible demand on people so
clearly there wasn't a God and he told
me and I and I believe him I've heard
this from other like agnostics and
atheists over the years because I've
been outspoken about being a Catholic
and many of my libertarian friends are
outspoken about being atheists but
several have confided in me in that
they're actually a little bit jealous
and as did Milton Friedman he said you
know I'm actually jealous of you
Marshall it's got to be easier to face
death thinking that there's a Hereafter
thinking that you're going to see
family and friends again and and it is I
got to do the the be the MC or whatever
it
my moral service and about 160 people
there and virtually all of them atheists
like Joe was and Joe was a very good
friend of mine and I said it's a nice
day to be a Catholic and all these folks
cringed what now is he going to talk
about I said one of the nice things
about Catholic soteriology big word for
getting to heaven nice thing about
Catholics soteriology is that we don't
have an exclusionary policy at all we've
made no statement that Hitler or or
Judas or in hell it's conceivable that
they're saved we believed in the
infinite mercy of Jesus Christ and I
said I'm convinced it's somewhere
between when Joe Furyk had the last
thought that we could see him having and
he fell to the floor and died instantly
that somewhere in that falling process
he met Jesus Christ and he said and
Jesus said to him you know you want to
spend eternity with me and Joe at that
moment didn't say Oh evolution saved me
our old technology saved me I suspect
Joe smart enough guy and said oh lord
save me
and Jesus said just about the time you
know his head's about to hit that cement
Jesus says ok done deal and you did that
one quickly last second but I really
believe when I get to heaven I'm gonna
see my friend Murray Rothbard
my friend Joe Furyk and my friend I want
to be the big botany sees many others
I'm gonna get to see Joe listening to
Murray and look Vic go at it on on the
Austrian economics and Joe trying to get
a word in edgewise me just sitting back
and enjoying it so anyway if you don't
know God search for him I got the
opportunity to witness to Milt Milton
Friedman
team permission he said yes I came back
and before I went I called I wanted to
give you the book Mere Christianity
write it down em er II Christianity it
is the most logical book it's the book
that deals starts with reason and for a
libertarian who wants reasoning mere
christianity by CS lewis is one fine
book to start with but i called up a
couple of Catholic friends Russell hit
injure and and Joseph SEO and and rest
said Oh Marshall book you should give
him as the problem of pain by CS Lewis
and father of SEO who lived in San
Francisco at the time is brilliant also
I said to him what book would you give
Milton Friedman said abolition a man my
my CS Lewis and I said by the way if he
nibbles at the Catholic faith will you
please take over and talk to him because
you know he's out of my league
completely and well it never did happen
but but I thought it odd that three
Catholics of priests and to laypeople
the best three books we could think
overall written by for a non-christian
to read the best books we could think of
were written by a Protestant Anglican so
it's a funny world out there but those
of the three books that I would
recommend another written by a
Protestant does American fellow Lee
Strobel still alive if you can oh god
but not Christ you have a sense that
there's a spirituality but you're not
thinking Christ is necessarily the guy
read the case for Christ by Lee Strobel
STR OBE L used to be the crime reporter
for the Chicago times and has just a
really interesting way of writing a book
now if you know Christ but you don't
know his church then you've gotta talk
to a couple of people because the the
Mormon missionaries are taught when
they're whenever they go to a Catholic
country you know so-called Catholic
country Italy or Mexico or whatever
they're taught to tell people this
there's two churches that have
a plausible case for being authoritative
for being authentic for being
authoritative for having authority from
God and those two churches are the Roman
Catholic Church and the Church of the
latter-day saints and we'd like to
present you here with the latter-day
Saint approach so by the way reminds me
of my only Catholic LDS Mormon joke do
you know what you get if you cross a
Mormon and a Catholic you get somebody
who will press the doorbell but then
doesn't know what to say
we're hoping to change that inside the
Catholic Church you can talk to mark
about what books he would recommend and
I'm sure he'll have some but if you're
of a Christian persuasion but have not
yet really studied the case for
Catholicism as the church that Jesus
Christ set up and wants us all to belong
to I would urge read many many books on
you but - that you might enjoy and start
with one is born fundamentalist
born-again Catholic by David Currie and
a second is surprised by truth by
Patrick Madrid and both of these are
biographies or autobiographies or an
autobiography of evangelical Protestants
in the main who somehow stumbled into
studying Roman Catholicism and went
through the three phases that GK
Chesterton says of conversion one is
condescension oh right I'll read the
Catholic stuff by the Catholics just to
be more knowledgeable about them so I
can more effectively debate them or
discuss with them so that's kind of
sentient and the next step is excitement
exhilaration oh wow this stuff is great
these guys had in the second third
fourth fifth century stuff that
we just to heaven today they had it
already this is this is fantastic and
they get very excited about Catholicism
and then they hit the third phase terror
oh I don't want to be a Catholic one of
my wife's a one of my children say and
is that the one minute warning or the
two minute gosh well I don't think I'll
be taking ten unless there's questions I
think Larry had it right about Graham
see Graham she's intent to grab the
cultural high places destroy the family
destroy the culture I'll toss in a third
book here by an Austrian economist
Thomas E woods at the junior at the at
Auburn at the Mises Institute how the
Catholic Church built Western
civilization and just a superb book by a
heavy-duty libertarian Austrian
economist but Graham she wanted to
destroy the family and as many of you
know I've been involved with the
Alliance for the separation of school
and state for 14 years and we are right
now in the process of rebranding it my
successor and to put more focus on the
family and we'd be you'll be hearing
more about this as we keep our original
separation of school of the state but
emphasize a new aspect of this called
the Alliance of free families families
which are free from government
involvement in their children's
education Bob Anderson at fie once said
he can think of three ways that the
government has inserted itself in the
family in America in the 1840s the
government came to the to the people and
said you don't have to worry about your
children's education we're going to take
over and do it for you we'll pay for it
or cause your neighbor to pay for it and
people said hot-diggity-dog I won't have
to pay tuition anymore
- they get Billy educated and then
another nine
in 30s they came to the children and
they said hey don't worry about mom and
dad we're gonna take care of them with
Social Security and now there's another
cleaver separating the family and then
in the 1960s they went to the women and
said don't worry about keeping papa
happy and bringing home the bacon you
can kick him out of the house and we'll
support you in fact if you let him back
in we'll stop supporting you so you can
have welfare as long as you don't have a
husband
so faster than the three musketeers the
government has gone slice and dice into
the American family and what do you see
now you see bastard he's celebrated you
see divorce becoming a sacrament we know
everything used phrases like broken
families anymore
our society is on some sort of a
nosedive down a slippery cliff
abandoning the morals of yesteryear and
Graham C is probably smiling in his
grave so those are my thoughts wise or
not those room that's my last lecture
don't know if I'm going to have another
opportunity I've only got six to 20
months and how many of these conferences
are we gonna heat would that be funny if
I was alive next year and they had to
have a repeat but anyway ladies and
gentlemen thank you very much for your
kind attention and I will take any
questions that you might have there's
two microphones there we are having
questions is that appropriate
[Applause]
an Intimidator class I doubt that piece
after all our libertarians well Marshall
is a little louder I'm Marty hearing on
that yes what is the status of the
separation of school and state at this
moment how would you say that things are
today versus when you started working on
that project and is there hope for the
future good question what is the status
of the movement for the separation of
school and state well first of all let's
recognize that this movement is so
massive that it's somewhat like the anti
slavery or the abolitionist movement
except that you have the vast majority
of the people owning slaves and that is
their neighbors and enslaving them
through taxes to pay for their
children's education so you've got a
much higher percentage of the population
that stands to lose money as they see it
so it's going to be a difficult effort
in fact it is a difficult effort because
we say to people you need to be more
responsible you brought these children
into the world and you know did you
expect other people to pay for their
food expect other people to pay for
their diapers did you expect the
government to provide your housing well
no no no well then why do you expect the
government to be PB taxing other people
to pay for their education it doesn't
make any sense especially if you're a
libertarian boy you want to become mr.
Poisson and non grata which I've done
any number of times I go to libertarian
events and you know what can we do
you can teach by example by taking your
own children and homeschooling them or
putting in a private school where they
agree you know religiously worldview
wise with your thoughts that's what you
can do otherwise if you're just flapping
your gums about free enterprise and
everything and using government schools
people nobody know you by what you do
and I stand before you a guilty customer
this sent all four of his children to
public schools so Mia culpa mea culpa I
know from where I speak on this and it
was out of ignorance you might say but
but also out of just covetousness I
wanted other people to pay for my
children's education so I wouldn't have
to and where is the movement the
movement we can liken it to I always
have I don't know if it's true or not
but my little metaphor is the
three-stage engine that did the moonshot
and I was in a very peripheral way
involved in part of that back in the
1960s extremely peripheral but stage one
its job that big Saturn 5 its job was to
break gravity and take the payload stage
to in the moon lunar modular and all
that it was to take that up to what I'll
call the sky it didn't have to be
terribly accurate it had to hit the sky
and break gravity and then boom boom
boom we've seen the movies of those
explosive broke bolts breaking stage one
loose and it floats off into the
Atlantic and of course it was before we
didn't in those days after pray it
doesn't hit any dolphins but anyway we'd
watch that thing float down there and
land in the Atlantic wonderful stage to
wet off and I always thought of myself
as the stage one guy it was my job to
get this bloomin thing up somewhat and
we have 30,000 people who have signed a
proclamation for the separation of
school and state a phrase that was
almost unheard of by anybody is now
mentioned in some four or five thousand
websites of which 2,000 or more refer to
our website I can remember in April 1994
just a few months after starting the
Alliance getting the opportunity to meet
Clarence Thomas and and I said man I
take a handshake back to Fresno and brag
that I met you sir and he said sure and
who are you and I said I'm Marshall
Fritz with the Alliance for the
separation of school
and state and he leaned back in less
than two seconds later it came slamming
down as cherish hit the boom and he said
ha I like that right there
last one in three-quarter seconds that
big mine just got all the way around
that thing but doesn't go that fast for
most people I'll tell you that and and
so I think it maybe may take us 50 years
my successor Alan Schafer is rebranding
this as the with our encouragement and
the board mine and others as the
Alliance of free families and and we'll
we'll talk about that some other time
outside or or whatever they brought with
me also a little brochure I'm developing
I have a wonderful new button that I'm
also developing here the Roman Catholic
Church is your friend asked me why and
I've got a little brochure that talks
about it II that if you want to stay an
atheist or a Mormon or a Muslim the
Roman Catholic Church is still your
friend and I'd be glad to give you one
of my little brochures ladies and
gentlemen god bless you thank you for
loving me thank you for letting me love
you good night this event was part of
Freedom Fest 2008 held in Las Vegas to
find out more about freedom fest visit
Freedom Fest com